we're an omelet do I relieve my legs I'm
but eggs like every day just got a
burger that sounds good yeah oh man oh
my god
I think that's of Daniel wait who
Tim's dog Nathaniel I think I'm gonna
say hi no Ali just stay here no I
shouldn't I know but I'm just gonna do
it so quickly okay I promise I'll be
right back
may then hi it's good to see you
you look good
are you still doing that thing where you
curl up on the green pillow I love that
pillow too
[Music]
well I got that promotion
[Music]
you always believed me so much
[Music]
yeah you're right I didn't forget lies
how hard this would be for me
I just really miss you and was just
wondering if you'd be okay if I could
pick you up
she does
um well does she scratch behind your
ears when you she does
I don't want another dog Nathaniel I
want you who's a good boy
Oh who's a good boy
I'm sorry that was inappropriate
sometimes I'm sitting on my couch
watching Netflix and I look down and my
hands just doing this there's nothing
there what if I just pet you real quick
for old times sake
oh so much Oh
[Music]
Tim hey hey good to see you
you too have a good day ladylike is
moving to our own new channel you're
going to find more of the great videos
you love click huge subscribe